by the way a quick update brian callan
was in the movie
one sentence and you don't see his face
you see his reflection off of a mirror
so
i just want to point out that he was in
the film he might have recorded more and
he plays like a
prostitute doesn't he no no no no no if
he had that big of a role
great he just plays another dude that's
in the clown in business
but he's in the backstage party you just
hear him say hey uh blah blah blah blah
blah
and then they move on to the next scene
you only see his face big star
because he's looking at a mirror but
like the camera's still like 20 feet
away
you know like if you don't know it was
brian callan you wouldn't have picked it
up
you know it would have been dope is it
brilliant how imaginable
uh taking that uh netflix deal because
now you have a netflix special
yeah if you didn't listen to your friend
brendan you'd have a netflix special
joker this would be your big year
but instead you're releasing your old
comedy specials on the fighter and the
kid
channel yeah wait no no oh yeah
i saw caller release his special results
on youtube yeah yeah
trying to get that like again leads me
to believe that he's got one foot out
the door and he's like i'm gonna get
some of this audience on my way out
you think so yeah it's yeah why wouldn't
you
right like if i thought this was gonna
be a wrap i'll be like yo i'm gonna get
a couple like my solo merch clips up
get that audience get those people out
one step too far sent this to us um and
this is at the moment brian callum
finally got it
uh this is from the fighter and the kid
yes they had a jim brewer danjin brew
ron and apparently brian callan's a big
jim brewer fan
and brandon chob's an idiot that's the
best description ever
oh we're gonna have a yeah we'll have
him in here in studio and of course he's
a huge fan and uh i'm a [ __ ]
so it's gonna be a good dynamic i think
[Laughter]
so jim brewer was in there and he was
all like yeah man
i gotta do this the whole time that's a
good brewer that's a good fruit talk
about the mets
you know he's he was great on the radio
but like yeah it's just after a while he
didn't tell someone look
to be fair he some of my favorite
stories that were ever told like an old
ona was jim brewer stories there so i
mean on the radio he's great when
somebody
do you talk about his dad dying his
bombs all of all that [ __ ] up [ __ ] he
just was so honest about it but when he
gets on stage it's like yeah
all right let's uh let's play this from
one step too far
i'm a huge fan because i keep wrapping
this stuff when they said you're coming
on
oh look at the by the way if look at the
comments brendan is the number one worst
interview number two goes to brendan as
well
that's a great comment brendan dude you
really need to stop
interrupting the guest you're literally
killing any momentum he's one of the
greats
that's the way people view you brother
well well
thank you take your shirt off and that's
not mike i'm not i'm you're not like a
niche comic or you know no you know that
that's what that means a lot to me more
than you know that's why you sell 1100
tickets
more than you know it means more because
uh as time goes on
uh it's i never was the a-lister type
guy or anything
we know go boy that world you didn't
feel that way i'm telling you
can you tell can you tell brendan is
sick of brenda that's right right you
can't right
brian is sick of brendan from
where i come from my friends and my
circle you're as a-list as it gets
well thank you yeah i think you need to
be reminded of that all right
that's why i'm saying it i need to
remind you
i'm gonna man i'm gonna tell my what
every ever okay so
listen every way brian we we figured
this out like with the hodge twins
the way brian even compliments people is
so moronic and insulting like he's
i'm sorry i'm going to say brendan is so
moronic and insulting you know what i
mean like
it's what he did with the hodge which
like you know you guys look like a bunch
of you know
roidy stupid magoos with with mush
brains but you're actually funny
he did that with brewer he's like he's
basically saying like look i don't care
if you're washed up bro in your career
thank you exactly me and my friends yo
we think you're all we think you're
a-list even though i mean come on you're
not
but to us it's like you're the best oh
jim brewer
exactly you know you could probably
talking to jim like
one of like if jim's wife or girlfriend
it's like you're still number one to me
baby
so yeah i get it yeah dude like even
though you could walk around your
hometown now
in your 50s and people probably won't
even bother you at the mall
yeah my friends think you're still
famous
i mean he's really terrible at this look
baby i don't think you're fat no matter
what my friends say
brendan shut up stop you're
always give not some phone call on my
wife after this that's right let me talk
you understand what's going on i'm gonna
call my wife you're gonna let my kids
know what time it is
though if you have if you have kids just
not letting anybody
get any breathing room they don't he
won't pass the ball to anybody
brewer said like three words brian
callan's like yeah
it's like jesus christ mike and i have
been doing this for a while and we
when we interview people we were pretty
good at like kind of looking at each
other until you know
who's taking over who's not and kind of
have a flow this
is just a steamroller you're doing a
show with a steamroller
like just go to go like pretend you're
brian callan and ask jim brewer a
question
so jim how's it going and then it's like
yo me and my homies
we would always watch like half baked
you know what i mean and like we would
get baked bro
and we would get baked and it was like
we were getting baked with you dude
that's all i'm saying dude are you
signing no dude i'm telling you
what we need to do whatever you do jim
don't do a netflix special i'll talk
everybody out of that [ __ ]
there's a bit of a like uh it's like
there's a resentment like i'm just like
man i'm missing
whoa i have three dates in november
there's a good chance my god
we have to watch that again don't we
brendan
hope i don't miss
jim is going to joke about it like
there's a resentment like i'm just like
man i'm missing stuff
or like yeah you know yeah i gotta miss
another kid come in no telling my kids
no we're reminded of that all right
he goes you need to be reminded of that
look at jim's reaction
to what to when brendan tells him that
and then listen as
brendan keeps going on interrupt base
frequency versus joe rogan look into it
bro
some of these i'm not gonna pay
attention to the commas are pretty good
and then he'd misses jim go jim brewer
looks like nate diaz in 20 years
it's a pretty good line joke that i was
about to so um
tell my wife always give me some phone
calling my wife after this that's right
let me talk
you understand what's going on i'm going
to call my wife you're going to let my
kids know what time it is
oh god he's terrible
take the shoes off the table
shoes on the table symbolically is a
very bad thing like that's
right yes you're not supposed to have
shoes even clean new shoes you don't put
shoes on a table
take the shoes off the table i believe
remember when uh
brendan schaub was [ __ ] ronda rousey
and then she just started [ __ ]
another dude and then that dude
allegedly let's let's allegedly
allegedly she left him for the other
dude it's not like
all right is that not like
she used to be with brendan shop then
she was no longer with brendan job
then she was with another fighter is
that inaccurate well you're missing the
middle with dana white
i didn't say that allegedly hey i see
you're the one i just said
remember when brendan schaub was [ __ ]
ronda rousey you know what i was saying
he started [ __ ] another fighter
and then that fighter helped turn his
[ __ ] brain into pudding
and the end it's an uplifting story you
know it's
it's funny because with with the whole i
was thinking about this we've talked
about
like i don't know if she ever did
anything with dana white or not but
remember when ronda rousey
i don't know if she did or not well i'm
just going to point something i remember
ronda rousey left
uh left the ufc
and she went to wwe
they did like an entire in a
pay-per-view at the ufc
dana white who's in charge did entire
like 15-minute vignette
for ronda rousey like she was look she
was good don't get me wrong and
obviously i'm just one of the first
females i get all that
but it was really out of character it
was kind of like
she was leaving and plugging that she
was going to wwe
and playing a hole like ronda rousey was
the number one fight after she got
kicked so hard in the head that she
never wanted to come back
that kick broke her it brokers it that
that destroyed her